important thing is is that they are
actually innately attracted that's what
I'm saying girls start off the feminine
energy does want the man though they
want the masculine
um but because they're jaded and then
they they had to what do you mean
because they're Jade they want the
masculine because no because because I
genuinely feel that they I'll say it's
from personal experience
I as a as a young girl that's why I was
remembered like I I have a very
traditional family my mother has stayed
at home took care of the kids my father
was the breadwinner for me that is
normal that is what I saw myself
envisioned myself with and
sadly because times have changed my my
mom started saying you can't just you
know rely on a guy you've got to also
have your craft you you've got to have
something to bring to the table so I
agreed I said yeah of course so I went
out there I spent the time on myself and
I really like worked on myself try to be
a good you know like a good Society sub
person in society but the thing is then
in that journey I became too masculine
right I overshot and then I'm starting
to give bro Vibes and and then of course
then these girls are asking why am I not
getting the guy the masculine guy well
one
um you're too masculine I know that
because I was there once I had to teach
myself I had to remind myself that I
need to tone it down there are certain
times where that's appropriate such as
when I'm in a more work situation and I
have to be more decisive but when I'm on
a date well I am different I I want I
want a masculine man I defined I
actually looked at myself when I said
what do I want do I want if I'm in a man
or do I want a masculine why did why did
your mom why do you think your mom um
encouraged you to be masculine if it
seemed to have worked out well for her
she got to provide her husband and like
very sad actually we had this
conversation and my mum said to me she
said in my times she said guys just came
up to me all the time now I will say
this my mom's very feminine she's like
the Damsel in Distress so she does
attract guys anyways but she was saying
like I would used to walk on the street
and I will see great quality men
everywhere like I feel like I can just
pick them off the street they're all
great but I don't know she said I don't
know what's going on she was like it
makes me really sad but I feel like
guys are not as High Caliber anymore and
I'm worried for my daughter I'm scared
that they're going to not be able to
deal with themselves
and they don't have that support person
either so so to compensate she's pushing
me on the other direction of being
self-sufficient but the danger of that
is that it's over it was overshot I
think that's a common problem now so
yeah like you said your mom's pushing
you that way just to go back on your
point of email for the fact that you
realized you was too masculine that is
that is what
men I think today are asking women to do
is just for me I've got female friends
that I've got boyfriends and they
sometimes they ask me for advice and I
just tell them look in the mirror and I
don't and I say look in the mirror and
I'm not talking about look at your body
your face I'm saying look in the mirror
and look at the person you're being when
you're going to restaurants like how are
you trying to you trying to dominate the
situation when you go to family
gathering trying to dominate like you
have to let your man be a man and
exactly women find the problem yeah do
you guys think there's a shortage of
husbands or wives
um actually that's an interesting
question
um I'd share I'd say there's a shortage
on husbands because men like it's just
not worth it like any logical one which
most men it's safe to say illogical I'd
say it just doesn't make sense
oh because they don't want to get
married yeah you're saying okay what do
you think shortage of husbands or wives
depends on where as I said in the west
so so this is England us
[Music]
I I I don't I'll be honest I don't pick
one pick one
um I would say men shortage of husbands
wives
um I can I'd like you to so you think
you sort of explained a little bit you
think it's because men don't want to get
married yeah um I I don't think it's
that men don't want to get married like
I'd love to get married but to the right
woman that I know that wouldn't like
just Chuck my [__] you know what I mean
because I have very big plans for my
future and I'm not trying to risk it for
no one because like if a woman could
marry me for a year and take everything
that I've worked for over all these
years and put every ounce of effort into
then like
as someone who wants to get into
business that does not seem like good
business you know like that sounds like
a bad move so me that's that's more of a
point to why I think there's less wives
so I think traditionally and even
currently men caught women we go out and
we try to find a woman so if we can't
find a woman I think that's the problem
now it's like we're not we're not making
it blunt enough like
men don't want to get married to the
current women and we have multiple
reasons for that like let's not talk
about only fans let's not talk about
masculine women like it's it's simple
like we just don't think women are good
enough now for us to settle down and
marry so do you think that women don't
think they're good enough for men or men
don't think they're good or do you think
it's um because I think that like women
don't think men are good enough for them
even if they're average
yeah that's the problem isn't it yeah
because if you look in history I don't
I think women dated and married average
guys historically because a lot a
question I ask on my show often is like
how much does your submission cost
and um and I say like to the point that
like he said quit your job tomorrow be
with the kids you do it yeah I've seen
you Austin for the Saturday and they
always say six figures even if they're
fives even though that's the percent how
much people how much men in the world
don't see yeah and I so then the next
question is always are you a top 10 girl
and they say no and so it's like you
have girls that are not top 10 asking
for a top 10 outcomes in order to submit
I think the word submit bothers women
just the word submit buffers them
construed to be honest I think they uh
I've heard this before someone I'm not
sure where but uh I heard that women
tend to think submission means slavery
like they think what the months is is
just absolutely final without reason you
know what I mean when submission really
is just um you know it's not that you
don't get to say in the matter it's just
that there's a leader and you're second
in command there's someone in primary
command but you're still in second in
command
and you have a lot of influence too it's
like like because you can
I mean ever every person knows like that
couple that's like really cute we're
like even even though the guy's in
charge like the woman's kind of in
charge because she's just so feminine
and kind of can can get him to like see
her point of view you know you get
there's a couple that comes to your head
right is that okay I'm gonna give you an
example it's a little bit extreme but
you actually see the very clear actually
this will it's controversial if you
think about it but it's the healthiest
relationships are from the BDSM
community and I will I will explain why
because I need to find healthy so I need
you to like if so I'm gonna claim this
the reason why I say it's healthy is in
order to be able to be in that type of
relationship because it is so extreme to
the point where sometimes there is a
chance of death yeah because people
engage in such extreme activities you
need extreme trust in order to get into
it is there is there any data that backs
this up so the the idea this just sounds
like this sounds crazy to me so I I know
I'm I'm going to give you the example
okay because things are so extreme
you're not just going to do it even
though it's a fantasy you're not going
to do it unless you trust that person
it's not going to actually kill you does
that make sense so you have to discuss
all the details you